PRINCE HARRY WITH NEW
REVELATIONS ABOUT HIS FRACTURED
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE ROYALS.
DURING AN INTERVIEW WITH OUR OWN
ANDERSON COOPER ON "60 MINUTES."
HE TALKED ABOUT THE PHYSICAL
ALTERCATION HE HAD WITH HIS
BROTHER OVER HIS RELATIONSHIP
WITH MEGHAN.
FIRST, I WANT YOU TO TAKE A
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> HE WAS SHOUTING AT ME.
I WAS SHOUTING BACK AT HIM.
IT WASN'T NICE.
IT WASN'T PLEASANT AT ALL, AND
HE SNAPPED, AND HE PUSHED ME TO
THE FLOOR.
>> HE KNOCKED YOU OVER?
>> HE KNOCKED ME OVER.
I LANDED ON THE DOG BOWL.
>> YOU CUT YOUR BACK.
>> I CUT MY BACK.
I DIDN'T KNOW IT AT THE TIME.
HE APOLOGIZED AFTERWARDS.
IT WAS A PRETTY NASTY
EXPERIENCE.
>> DO YOU SPEAK TO WILLIAM NOW?
DO YOU TEXT?
>> CURRENTLY NO.
BUT I LOOK FORWARD TO US BEING
ABLE TO FIND PEACE.
>> HOW LONG HAS IT BEEN SINCE
YOU SPOKE?
>> A WHILE.
>> DO YOU SPEAK TO YOUR DAD?
>> WE HAVEN'T SPOKEN FOR QUITE A
WHILE.
NOT RECENTLY.
>> CAN YOU SEE A DAY WHEN YOU
WOULD RETURN AS A FULL-TIME
MEMBER OF THE ROYAL FAMILY?
>> NO.
I CAN'T SEE THAT HAPPENING.
>> THAT WAS AN AMAZING
REVELATION FOR ME.
HE ALSO OPENED UP ABOUT HIS
DECADES' LONG STRUGGLE WITH
GRIEF FOLLOWING THE DEATH OF HIS
MOTHER, PRINCESS DIANA.
THE INTERVIEW WAS THE FIRST
ADVANCE OF THE PUBLICATION OF
HIS BOOK.
THE RELEASE IS ON LINE IN THE
U.S. TONIGHT.
JOINING US OUR COLLEAGUE AND WHO
DID THAT INTERVIEW ON "60
MINUTES" OF PRINCE HARRY,
ANDERSON COOPER.
ANDERSON, GOOD MORNING, GOOD TO
SEE YOU.
SO MANY REVELATIONS HERE.
MY FIRST QUESTION IS WHAT STOOD
OUT TO YOU MOST ABOUT THIS
INTERVIEW?
MOST REVEALING TO YOU?
>> I READ THE BOOK.
IT'S 416 PAGES.
IT'S A VERY NUANCED AND DETAILED
PORTRAIT OF THIS MAN'S LIFE.
I THINK WE ALL GREW UP WATCHING
HIM.
ALL OF US HAVE SEEN PRINCE HARRY
AND HIS BROTHER FROM THE TIME
THEY WERE BORN, AND WE FEEL LIKE
WE KNOW WHO THEY ARE.
YET, WHEN YOU READ THE BOOK,
VERY QUICKLY YOU REALIZE WE
DON'T KNOW THAT MUCH ABOUT
WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON IN THE
INNER LIFE OF HARRY AND HOW HE
SEES HIMSELF AND HIS
RELATIONSHIP WITH HIS BROTHER
WHICH HE SAYS IN THE BOOK HAS
BEEN ON A DIFFERENT COURSE SINCE
THE DEATH OF THEIR MOTHER.
THAT DEATH IS THE CENTRAL EVENT
OBVIOUSLY IN HARRY'S LIFE.
HE WRITES EXTENSIVELY ABOUT
THIS.
THIS IS A MEMOIR IN MANY WAYS
ABOUT GRIEF AND LOSS AND THE TRA
JEK
J
TRAJECTORY AND HOW IT CHANGES
ONE'S LIFE.
>> IT CAME IN FULL CIRCLE.
YOU STARTED THE PIECE WITH
WILLIAM AND HARRY WALKING BEHIND
THEIR MOTHER'S CASKET AND YOU
ENDED WITH THEM WALKING BEHIND
THEIR GRANDMOTHER'S CASKET, BUT
HOW CHANGED A RELATIONSHIP THEY
HAD.
OBVIOUSLY WE KNOW, BECAUSE YOU
PUT IT OUT PUBLICLY IN YOUR
PODCAST AND TALKED ABOUT, THE
GRIEF YOU'VE GONE THROUGH WITH
DEATHS IN YOUR OWN FAMILY.
I WONDER WHAT IT'S LIKE AS
SOMEONE WHO LOST A PARENT AS A
TEENAGER.
MY DAD DIED A FEW WEEKS BEFORE
PRINCESS DIANA.
I REMEMBER HER DEATH SO WELL.
WHAT IT WAS LIKE FOR YOU TO HEAR
HIM DETAIL HIS GRIEF IN THAT WAY
THAT WE'VE NEVER HEARD PUBLICLY
BEFORE.
>> TO ME WHEN I READ THE BOOK, I
AGREED TO DO THIS INTERVIEW
BEFORE I HAD TO CHANCE TO
ACTUALLY READ THE BOOK BECAUSE
THERE WERE ALL THESE SECURITY
PROTOCOLS TO EVEN GET A COPY OF
THE BOOK.
WHAT JUMPED OUT TO ME IS THIS IS
A STORY OF GRIEF AND LOSS.
IT IS A HUGE PART OF THE BOOK,
AND IT INFUSES A LOT OF WHAT THE
WAY I THINK PRINCE HARRY SEES
WHAT IS HAPPENING NOW AND HIS
CONCERNS ABOUT WHAT IS HAPPENING
NOW, AND I THINK THAT IDEA OF
THE WALK THAT THEY TOOK BEHIND
THEIR MOTHER'S CASKET WHICH WAS
SUCH A FORMATIVE -- IT IS THE
INDELIBLE IMAGE FROM THE FUNERAL
IN EARLY SEPTEMBER OF 1997, AND
THAT WALK BEHIND THEIR
GRANDMOTHER'S CASKET.
IN MANY WAYS IT WAS A SIMILAR
WALK IN THAT THEY WERE TOGETHER,
BUT THEY WERE APART.
THEY WERE APART BY GRIEF BACK
WHEN HARRY WAS 12 AND WILLIAM
WAS 15.
HARRY COULDN'T CRY ABOUT IT
UNTIL HIS MOTHER WAS ACTUALLY
BURIED.
HE COULDN'T EVEN TALK ABOUT IT
REALLY WITH ANYONE FOR MUCH OF
HIS LIFE, AND HE HAD THIS SORT
OF MAGICAL THINKING IN THE YEARS
AFTER SHE DIED EVEN UP UNTIL HIS
EARLY 20s THAT HE THOUGHT MAYBE
SHE WAS STILL ALIVE.
IT'S NOT THAT HE THOUGHT SHE HAD
FAKED HER DEATH.
IT'S JUST HE THOUGHT -- IT WAS
SORT OF A MAGICAL THINKING WHICH
OCCURS WITH MANY PEOPLE WHO HAVE
LOST SOMEBODY, IMAGINING THAT
MAYBE THEY'RE STILL OUT THERE,
THINKING YOU SEE THEM IN PLACES.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT HE
BELIEVED AND HE SAYS HE HAD
DISCUSSIONS WITH HIS BROTHER
ABOUT AS WELL.
>> I THINK WE HAVE THAT MOMENT
IN THE INTERVIEW.
IT REALLY STOOD OUT.
>> YOU DIDN'T BELIEVE SHE WAS
DEAD.
>> FOR A LONG TIME.
I JUST REFUSED TO ACCEPT THAT
SHE WAS GONE.
PART OF -- SHE WOULD NEVER DO
THIS TO US, BUT ALSO PART OF
MAYBE THIS IS ALL PART OF A
PLAN.
>> YOU REALLY BELIEVED THAT
MAYBE SHE HAD DECIDED TO
DISAPPEAR FOR A TIME.
>> FOR A TIME AND SHE WOULD CALL
US AND WE WOULD COME AND JOIN
HER.
>> HOW LONG DID YOU BELIEVE
THAT?
>> YEARS.
MANY, MANY YEARS.
WILLIAM AND I TALKED ABOUT IT AS
WELL.
HE HAD SIMILAR THOUGHTS.
>> YOU WRITE IN THE BOOK, YOU
SAY I'D OFTEN SAY IT TO MYSELF
FIRST THING IN THE MORNING,
MAYBE THIS IS THE DAY.
MAYBE THIS IS THE DAY SHE WOULD
REAPPEAR.
>> YEAH, HOPE.
I HAD HUGE AMOUNTS OF HOPE.
>> ANDERSON, ONE THING HE TOLD
YOU WAS HE STRUGGLED TO EVEN
TALK ABOUT IT REALLY TO OTHER
PEOPLE, ABOUT HER DEATH.
DID YOU GET A SENSE OF WHY HE'S
TALKING NOW AND WHY HE GAVE SUCH
AN IN DEPTH INTERVIEW TO YOU?
>> WELL, I MEAN, LOOK, THERE'S A
LOT OF DIFFERENT WAYS TO LOOK AT
THAT AND A LOT OF IT DEPENDS ON
WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT PRINCE
HARRY PROBABLY AND HIS WIFE
MEGHAN.
HE WILL SAY I HAVE BEEN SILENT
FOR MY ENTIRE LIFE.
I'VE HAD ENDLESS STORIES WRITTEN
ABOUT ME AND PEOPLE PROJECTING
THINGS ON TO ME AND SAYING
THINGS ABOUT ME, AND THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR ME TO ACTUALLY
TALK ABOUT WHO I AM AND HOW I
SEE THINGS AND THE CENTRAL ROLL
THAT MY MOTHER'S DEATH HAS
PLAYED IN HIS LIFE.
OBVIOUSLY CRITICS OF HIS WILL
LOOK AND SAY, LOOK, HE AND HIS
WIFE HAVE LEFT THE ROYAL FAMILY.
THEY HAVE BEEN ACCUSED OF
CASHING IN ON THEIR ROYAL
TITLES.
THEY ARE NOT JUST TELLING THEIR
STORY.
THEY'RE MAKING ACCUSATIONS
AGAINST MEMBERS OF THE ROYAL
FAMILY WHICH IS PART OF THEIR
STORY AS WELL, THEY WOULD SAY.
SO OBVIOUSLY PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
SEE IT DIFFERENT WAYS.
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS PART OF A
MULTI-BOOK DEAL THAT HARRY
SIGNED WITH PENGUIN RANDOM
HOUSE.
THERE WAS THE NETFLIX SERIES
WHICH DETAILS MORE OF THE
FRACTURE WITH THE ROYAL FAMILY
AND THEIR LIVES AS A COUPLE I.
THINK THE BOOK, THOUGH -- THE
FOCUS FOR MOST PEOPLE ON THE
BOOK, OBVIOUSLY, ARE THE
REVELATIONS OF THE DRAMA GOING
ON BE LINED THE SCENES AND THE
ACCUSATIONS BACK AND FORTH.
WHEN YOU READ THE BOOK, THOUGH,
IT IS VERY MUCH A MEMOIR OF THIS
PERSON'S LIFE, AND THE FULL ARC
OF THEIR LIFE AND REALLY A STORY
OF GRIEF AND EARLY CHILDHOOD
TRAUMA.
>> ANDERSON, BEFORE YOU GO --
POPPY TALKED ABOUT YOU LOSING A
FAMILY MEMBER.
I LOST MY DAD, MY SISTER, MY
GRANDMA.
>> IN THE SAME YEAR, RIGHT?
>> IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE YOU
NEVER GET THOSE PEOPLE BACK, BUT
HE STILL HAS HIS BROTHER IN HIS
LIFE.
THAT WAS THE SAD PART FOR ME,
WHEN HE SAID I DON'T THINK I'LL
EVER BE A MEMBER OF THE ROYAL
FAMILY AGAIN, WHICH TRANSLATED
TO ME, I DON'T THINK I CAN REAL
THIS RIFT.
I HOPE THEY CAN.
HIS BROTHER IS STILL HERE.
>> HE ACTUALLY SAYS -- HE WOULD
MAKE A DISTINCTION.
THE QUESTION FOR HIM WAS REALLY
A PUBLIC -- A SENIOR ROLE IN THE
ROYAL FAMILY, LIVING IN ENGLAND,
WORKING FULL TIME FOR THE ROYAL
FAMILY AS HE WAS, THAT HE
DOESN'T SEE HAPPENING.
HE CERTAINLY HOLDS OUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF A PARTIAL ROLE
CONTINUED IN THE ROYAL FAMILY.
HE SAYS THAT THE OFFER THAT WAS
MADE TO -- THIS IS NOT -- THIS
CAME OUT IN THE INTERVIEW, WE
DIDN'T INCLUDE IT IN THE PIECE,
BUT JUST FOR TIME.
BUT HE SAYS THAT A PARTIAL ROLE
IS STILL ON THE TABLE.
THE ORIGINAL OFFER WHICH WAS
LIVING OVERSEAS FOR A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF MONTHS A YEAR AND THEN
FULFILLING DUTIES FOR THE ROYAL
FAMILY FOR PART TIME OF THE
YEAR, THAT IS STILL ON THE
TABLE.
THERE WOULD STILL NEED TO BE A
NUMBER OF CONVERSATIONS AND
DISCUSSIONS AND FRANK
DISCUSSIONS THAT DON'T LEAK OUT
BEFORE THAT WOULD HAPPEN.
SO HE HOLDS OUT.
HE CERTAINLY SAYS HE WANTS A
RELATIONSHIP WITH -- HE LOVES
HIS BROTHER, LOVES HIS FATHER.
HE SAYS HE WANTS A RELATIONSHIP
WITH ALL OF THEM.
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S MAYBE EVEN MORE
DIFFICULT TO IMAGINE RIGHT NOW
GIVEN THE REVELATIONS HE HAS
BROUGHT FORTH.
BUT HE SAYS HE'S NOT DOING IT IN
A HURTFUL MANNER, AND HE VERY
MUCH WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A
DIALOGUE.